[موسيقى]
ارضها بكر مكسوه بالخضره وباطنها يكتنز
الثروات الدوله الثانيه في افريقيا من حيث
المساحه والثالثه من حيث عدد السكان انها
جمهوريه الكونغو الديمقراطيه
[موسيقى]
تنام وتصحو عاصمتها على اهم كنوز الارض
وهي غارقه في فقرها نقص في الخدمات وتواضع
في البناء التحتيه اهميه هذه المقاطعه
بالنسبه للعالم كبيره جدا لذلك غضت موطنا
للتنافس بين الدول العظمى وكبريات الشركات
في العالم جوالك الذي تحمله وحاسبك الشخصي
الذي تستخدمه والسيارات كهربائيه وارواح
الطاقه الشمسيه واي منتج يعتمد على
البطاريه في تشغيله يحتاج بالتاكيد الى ما
تحت ارض هذه المنطقه وهو الكوبالت العنصر
الرئيسي في صناعه البطاريات وحفظ الطاقه
[موسيقى]
في هذا المنتج المتاخم لطرف المدينه هنا
يقضي اليكسموتومبو سحابه نهاره بحثا عن
الكوبالت عبر طرق التنقيب الشعبيه يدرك ان
ما يستخرجونه يوازي الذهب والنفط غير انه
ورفاقه يتلقون اجرا هزيلا يعزوا الامر الى
سيطره الشركات الصينيه على السوق هنا
باسكو انهم يهتمون فقط باستثماراتهم
الخاصه ليس لديهم منافسون هنا سوى انفسهم
لذا فان السوق تحت ايديهم الاسعار التي
يقدمونها لنا سيئه
انتجت ارض الكونغو ما يقارب ثلاثه ارباع
الانتاج العالمي للكوبالت العام الماضي
وبكميه تعد الاكبر مقارنه بالدول المنتجه
الاخرى مثل روسيا واستراليا كما تملك نصيب
الاسد من الاحتياط العالمي
صور الاقمار الاصطناعيه التي حصلت عليها
الجزيره وقام بتحليلها فريق فني متخصص
رصدت نشاط الشركات الصينيه فيما يعرف
بحزام الكوبال تلك التنجي الجنوبي البلاد
وتؤكد نتائج تحليل واحداثيات صور المناجم
سيطره الصين على اغلبها في الكونغو سواء
بالتشغيل او بالشراء من المنقبين المحليين
وعلى امتداد مساحه شاسعه في مقاطعه
استحوذت الشركات الصينيه على التنكيب
نتيجه اتفاقات ابرمت عام 2006 تمنحها
امتيازات في التنقيب والشراء مقابل تطوير
البنى التحتيه وتعطيها كلمه الفصل في
تحديد اسعار الكوبالت الذي تشتريه من
المستخرجين
وحسب احصائيات الرسميه فان مهنه التنقيب
عن المعادن هي اكثر المهن رواجا في البلاد
لا سيما في منطقه لالوبا حيث اغلب مناجم
التعدين في الجنوب لكن المعدنين على ما
يبدو تحتوي صايه صينيه بلا منافس ولا رقيب
في التحكم باسعار شراء الكوبالت
تغيير النظام الحالي يتطلب منا تحديد
مناطق استكشاف خاصه بالمعدنين المحليين
مموله من غير الصينيين هذه الطريقه
الوحيده لتحسين النظام
حكومه كينشاسا نددت في منتصف فبراير هذا
العام بما وصفته بعدم التوازن وشجب
التبديده ثروات البلاد عبر اتفاقيه
التعاون مع مجموعه الشركات الصينيه
سيكامينز الموقعه عام 2006 وذكر تقرير
مفتش عام الماليه ان عوائد الدوله من
الاتفاقات المبرمه مع صينيين لم تحقق
غاياتها وانها ضعيفه مقارنه بمكاسب
الشركات
الخلل الذي رصدناه صارخ عبر هذا الاتفاق
تم بيع وتبديد معادننا وهناك ايضا عدد من
ابناء بلدنا المضللين كانت لهم يد مع
الشركات الصينيه في هذا العمل المروع ضد
بلدنا
الاتفاقات مع الشركات الصينيه تضمن قائمه
طويله من مجموعه البناء التحتيه المختلفه
بينها الخدمات والاسكان والطاقه الا ان
حكومه كينشاسا تجزم انه لم يتحقق اي منها
على ارض الواقع
مراجعه العقود مع الشركات الصينيه
وادانتها بمخالفات ربما تدفعان الحكومه
الكنغوليه الى فتح الباب امام دول وشركات
اخرى للاستثمار في هذا القطاع الحيوي بعد
الخيبات التي جنتها من العمل مع الصين
قياده اعتقد انه في الوقت الراهن غدت هذه
المعادن الاستراتيجيه يعلم جميعا انه
يتعين علينا مشاركه الانتاج بشكل عادل كما
يدرك الصينيون ذلك جيدا والانتاج اليوم
يكفي لاطعام السوق الصيني وسوقنا المحلي
يؤمن الكونغوليون ان بلادهم تعد احد كنوز
افريقيا الثمينه وانما فيها من صراع او
هدر لثروات انما هو نتيجه تنافس دولي
عليها وافاقات اداريه ورقابيه وسياسيه من
قادتها ويوظفت امكانياتها فانها موعوده
بان تكون في مصافي الدول الغنيه والمتقدمه
كما تامل هذه الاغنيه الشهيره عندهم ان
تكون دره اقتصادي فريقيه وتاجا لنهضتها
ونمائها محمد الطيب الجزيره في مقاطعه
لالوبا